hi guys hey
yo it's so good to see you
yes no i just saw you this morning on
screen
right
yep as did i i watched it this morning
every time i'm i'm astonished by the
same things
number one charlie looks exactly the
same to me
i'm sure if you did a side by side yeah
that's there but
in my mind that's what you look like
sure
and glenn is incredibly funny like in in
ways that i forget about and then i'm
reminded of and then i'm reminded of
that of being in the editing room and
watching both of you guys
and just being like what the [ __ ]
how am i gonna catch up with these guys
he's he's unintentionally insulted both
of us did you notice that he said you
look young
but i'm funny yeah so in other words you
look young but you weren't that funny
yeah and i'm funny but you're looking
old yeah
you know what it is
that's a that's such a pessimistic way
of looking at things yeah yeah yeah yeah
i picked up on it too
like i'm pretty [ __ ] funny in that
episode yeah unbelievably my god this is
what it's like
listeners this is what it's like working
with these guys
they take no compliments they turn them
into
insulting insults well in my mind you
guys are both those guys as well so even
though we're much older and
many many years of
past decades actually um uh you guys
that's those are still
when i look at you i see those two
younger guys yeah that's interesting if
i look closely i i see
there's a difference i don't have to
look that close
i love this episode me too
yeah
you know what i really like just the
beginning scene of us just sitting at
the table
and it feels loose and real in a way and
conversational
where we're just not going for any jokes
too hard but it's also really funny
but it's very natural well and in that
first scene uh it was not written in the
script that you couldn't read
that's that's right that document that
was something that you just wanted to do
you were like let me do i'm going to try
something and you just like and i
distinctly remember you glenn being like
this is so dumb and then me being like i
think it's dumb too
but it's also funny and you're like wait
are we literally saying we're on set and
you're like are we literally saying that
charlie can't read right and we were
like i can't and charlie is like yeah i
guess so
guys let me get you let me i got you
guys covered on this one
this is going to play this is going to
play you were right i don't remember
having objections to it but i don't know
why i would object to him doing one take
no
it wasn't certainly like hey don't do
that it was more like wait are we making
a massive character choice right now on
the fly in the middle of a scene but
this is a funny thing about about
charlie day not charlie kelly but
charlie day is that he is both
constantly making his own character
dumber and dumber yes and also
complaining about how dumb his character
is getting to us as we're writing things
maybe that's the clown this is true this
is a very true thing that you're
pointing out yeah i mean you you
yourself just to me you're like you're
like trust me this is going to play you
know and you know sort of
implying you had to talk us into you
know giving your character like an
incredibly uh you know stupid uh
character i mean a funny one but a
stupid one
a character trait that makes him stupid
um but yeah as we're writing it you're
you're you're always upset that you're
you feel like your character's getting
too clownish and too dumb yeah i guess
we did talk about that in the last one
didn't we yeah clown baby yeah yeah or
or now like in the later years not not
clownish enough or something right
no i'm constantly doubting my things i'm
just very sure of my opinions that i
then later doubt well yeah yeah well
in the moment i'm crystal clear and then
you know weeks after the fact i'm just
like i don't know i don't know
that's a good quality though yeah
because i i think you know you you you
you have both things in your head at the
same time you recognize how funny it is
when your character sometimes is really
uh stupid or maybe even stupider than it
even makes sense for the character to be
given what we've shown the character to
be like in the past or whatever
um that it's super duper funny
but you're afraid of losing like the
grounded quality and like the real
the real uh feelings and intentions that
the character like really needs stuff
and that he you know really exists as a
real person in this world and yet when
we go too far in that direction you're
like
you you're you're ups you you get upset
that you're not you don't you're not
getting enough funny [ __ ] to do like you
you're like you're making him two like
we're making him too real too he's just
the voice of reason voice of reasoning
yeah yeah exactly yeah i don't know it's
funny it's it's a kind of a push pull in
that way i i
weirdly feel like we all have that you
have that with like how evil your
character might get right i do yes that
is true this is too arched to evil
totally yeah yeah and yet and yet i also
push it in arch and evil directions
myself so i do the exact same thing
because i'm i'm always like is it
getting too like too serial killery too
like
too creepy this is the creative process
right it's uh you know am i a serial
killer am i not yeah that's the process
this is the process right you kill one
person you're like well i'm a murderer
but i'm not cereal not for me
i didn't get the satisfaction out of
that and then you stop right so you're a
murderer but you're not a serial number
then you try a second one you try it
again you're like okay maybe i'm
starting to see the
something to this right and then it's
definitely easier this time by the third
and fourth you're like you know it'd be
cool if i could talk to cops a little
bit so you start with like messaging
right right like and then next thing you
know you look back on it and you've got
a great body of work
can i can i make a whole sentence like
can i make a whole sentence or only one
word out of this guy's teeth yeah
you know what i mean you're still going
to need more i'm going to need more guys
so i'll start with the word a phrase at
a time then the cops will put it
together and then right by the time of
collecting each victim you you can make
one word out of their teeth and then you
put it all together and there's a
message in there that's the creative
process and i'm sure i'm sure
that's the creative process
yeah and i'm sure a lot of the murderers
are like you know am i going too far
with the messaging here you know like am
i too psychotic
and then they complain they're like oh
this other guy's way more psychotic than
me that's like you know yeah that's
right right they don't want to be looked
down on as just simply crazy it's like
you don't call me crazy i'm a genius i'm
an artist you know what i mean they're
almost upset but then some other serial
killer does something that's way crazier
than what you did and you're like well
that
don't show me up well
are they changing with the times as well
are they looking at the are they looking
at their body of work and saying you
know i need to be more inclusive
right so they're changing with the
culture as well in other words they're
they feel like i've killed too many
white ladies exactly
yeah sure i'm sure they feel those
pressures yeah yeah well everyone does
they don't want to get they don't want
to get canceled for that sure um
there i would i would actually say that
there there's an argument to be made
that like making dennis a serial killer
or like
like we're suggesting that maybe he is
is less
potentially less evil than what we're
kind of doing in these episodes because
because once you go to that place you're
like oh this is like a cartoon it's very
clearly satire
whereas this one like
charlie is
is like in this woman's apartment and
just like casually she's saying no over
and over and over again and charlie's
like right being like i'm not leaving
and like but he's so likable that i know
he's still lovable he gets away he gets
away with it but when you look at it and
you're like well we're not really
commenting on that aspect of it so we
were like blind to that because we were
like oh everybody
we weren't remotely blind to that like
are you kidding me like completely aware
that that was inappropriate for the
character to be doing and that's where
the humor was coming from which is like
this poor girl has to deal with this
guy's terrible behavior
[Laughter]
yeah
she was only 11 when we shot that and
then by the way
we also then
then in this episode uh suggest that
she's a terrible person as well which is
the first time we really said well
no okay now that actually brings up an
interesting thing because this there's a
very little massive inconsistency
in this episode that makes no sense what
is that and the reason it makes no sense
is because we aired this episode after
an episode
that was previous to this oh the
macbank's dennis's mom
yes so so it's
they're talking we're talking about the
waitress as if frank didn't sleep with
her which he does
in the episode right so i remember what
happened was they loved the fx loved
that episode so much and we did frankly
and the welfare welfare ones yes they
pushed both of them up yeah and hundred
dollars and they were like we want to
put these in the front and kick this one
to the
later part of the season and we were
like that doesn't really make any sense
because it doesn't really track we know
that dennis slept with her
that happened in season one yes yeah but
we don't know that but then frank says
what's with frank's with the uh
charlie's with the waitress girl it
doesn't make any sense and the network
was like we don't care and at the end of
the day it doesn't seem like the
audience cares
yeah it was supposed to be the it was
supposed to be the third episode it was
supposed to come right after the gang
goes jihad i mean that's what we're
talking about in the beginning like we
burned a building down i mean i think
you could easily miss that if you're not
tracking the arc of it you'd just be
like i guess they burned a building down
i don't know oh yeah yeah or well they
finally went to court right yeah but i
think it just plays like dennis slept
with her in the past
but it didn't bump me so much with the
it's the conversation it's the
conversation with frank where he's just
like what's the deal with this waitress
and who is she like yeah he he had sex
with her yeah but always and then she
freaked out and then you cried all he
says is that charlie's with that
waitress which was a fake tear i
remember was it
well no it wasn't no you know what it
was that was that just you you held your
eyes open yeah yeah yeah that's what my
eyes were just a real tear though i was
funny because i remember how you worked
hard to get that out and it worked so
well with the timing of it
but like
no no the trick and the technique for
uh young aspiring actors at home is
sometimes you do a few takes you can
really get it sometimes you're like oh
we need one more you're like well i
can't [ __ ] get tear up right and if
you just don't blink for a while those
eyes get nice and sure nice and dry or
they come and blow those uh crystals
into your eyes we didn't have a crystal
budget
what are those it's like menthol menthol
crystals so yeah this is great a lot of
people don't realize this but yeah a lot
of a lot of crying actors uh you know
people probably won oscars
uh you know off of a crying scene where
really all that happened was a makeup
artist came and they have this this
thing where they blow air through
um
what is it oh yeah menthol crystals
and so it's literally blowing minty
menthol air in directly into your eyes
right before you shoot something so
you're just crying like a [ __ ]
because it really stings yeah no it's
amazing that's how sometimes they get
kids to cry yeah think about this listen
right right they're literally taking
children and blowing menthol crystals
into their eye to get them out people
already don't like us out here in
hollywood don't tell them abusing the
children the kids in this episode are
fantastic yeah their little performances
little because they're little but like
the kid who gets like spiked on the back
with the pen yeah he nails like the
the realness of like
getting nailed with that pin is great
yeah yeah yeah can we flop kids flip
flops
and his socks who raises his head thanks
dad yeah that that part makes me laugh
so hard like
yeah basically like implying that like
this kid is the one father figure this
kid has ever had yeah and it's and you
quickly crush his dreams
yeah
i remember that we'd shut that
basketball by the way i think the
direction of this episode is really good
dan addius again yeah like the coverage
is good and um
we shot that basketball sequence first
up in the morning
and you know i had gotten a set and i'd
had my breakfast burrito and a full like
cup of coffee and got out started
running around remember being like
i'm gonna throw up all over these kids
and yet you uh did some pretty
extraordinary uh physical feelings one
shot is so great yeah that shot and i
remember it was just continuous yeah
where he throws the ball
again and then continues
stuff that kid's the heart is great that
felt good oh of course this feels good
to stuff somebody even that was it's not
like that was planned it's not like this
was a
free-for-all well choreographed uh no it
was a total free-for-all yeah yeah i
think we thought it was so funny that we
went and got an extra spiking shot
there's another shot where i spike your
cableway let's just get a close-up like
from low of me stuff and something yeah
this is the first time i think maybe i'm
maybe i'm incorrect i think this is the
first time we refer to dee as a bird
because i remember later on you guys are
talking about her as larry bird but i
say that she looks like big bird yeah
and this wasn't even the first step like
this wasn't the beginning of us calling
her bird the beginning of us calling her
a bird was the larry bird joke in the
serial killer episode in season three
this just it just happens to be a joke
that happened a year before we sort of
discovered that joke yes because she did
because she did look like big bird but
that was based on we i remember us
looking up
talking to costumes and like being like
we had a very specific idea in our head
of like what this pants suit should look
like
and finding pictures on the internet to
show the wardrobe department to be like
this this is the kind of pants suit that
we're yeah you know we want her to wear
yeah i love that there was this was
there a specific coach wasn't there a
specific coach that that used to wear
pants suits like that or something there
was a female that's like one of the most
successful female coaches of all time
her name's pat we'll have to look at
maggi can you can we do a little
research i think she her name was pat
her first name was pat okay
she used to wear a good a nice solid
pant suit yeah i think we used her as a
reference one color just top to bottom
pant suit i'm not i feel like i remember
there being some discussion about that
outfit being like is this too cartoony
i don't remember yeah maybe
pat summitt pat summitt
pets uh and are you finding pictures of
pat summitt and is she wearing a
unicolor pantsuit
let's see let's have a look oh yeah
there it is i believe yeah there's pat
there it is good for her yeah
does it upset you guys to think about uh
the fact that the kids that are in that
episode are probably 35 years old now
yeah yeah that's disturbing yeah
they're maybe not that old but they're
probably i mean how old are they they're
definitely in their mid to late 20s
yeah oh yeah oh definitely right because
they were 11 oh let's say they're in
their late 20s let's say they were 11
years old in 2006 so yeah they're
they're like 26 27 years old now oh sure
sure wow hey maybe this is interesting
basketball huh
rob you used to play a lot of basketball
you used to go to the y oh yeah that's
actually true big basketball
no i was not a good basketball player
when you played basketball we played
every saturday we played every saturday
yeah with uh with chris baxter chris
bacchus has come up a number of we're
gonna we're gonna make sure we find a
way to mention chris back we gotta bring
miss it do you miss your basketball
playing days uh do you have regrets uh
do you feel as though you could have
accomplished more uh walk us through
your playing days and uh
it was fun i mean yeah it was like
saturdays it was great it was fun it was
it was actually something to look
forward to because like all week long
we'd have like no auditions or maybe
you'd get an audition and then there
would be like nothing to do you know i'd
work at the [ __ ] restaurant glenn
didn't he would be watching movies
well yeah i i had a lot of that show you
guys are going head to head in a game of
hoops who's winning oh i don't know i
mean i at this point i have no i have no
clue i don't if i could outlast his bot
his body because he's got some back
issues
oh no remember you [ __ ] your ankle up
you rolled your ankle that's why i feel
bad one time yeah that's why like
straight to the emergency room [ __ ]
correct did you take me to the emergency
room who told me i had to keep playing
man i was wondering no no not no i think
i think you did take me to the emergency
room thanks buddy yeah
um
yeah that was uh yeah we used to play i
i was the same way i really really
enjoyed that game it was super super fun
we would all play and then a lot of
times we'd go get brunch afterwards just
a bunch of sweaty dudes how long did you
wait in that emergency room quite a
while
um i don't remember god i don't even
remember i think we went to
i don't even remember what emergency
room we went to i feel like we drove all
the way to a cedar side i think we came
back over the other side of this yeah
because we lived in west hollywood i
think you took me to cedars-sinai and
then and andrea oh and
mattis there yeah yeah my girlfriend at
the time you're yeah but he probably
went right in because i remember we
thought it was like broken it was like
his leg they'll let you sit in them
waiting on the bro you could have your
dangling off your body like all right
take a seat right yeah i don't remember
it being that bad but i do remember when
i came down what happened was i went up
for a layup and i came down on someone's
foot she said you know something that
happens in basketball all the time and
it was audible yeah you could like you
could hear it you could hear it through
the gym you were screaming i remember
like it was we're like this guy [ __ ]
broke everything it was
i i still shiver thinking about it like
it's it traumatized me to the point
where after that even after it healed
and was like totally healed
i was never the same again i couldn't
i was never that great of a basketball
player the one thing i had going for me
was i was fast and i was aggressive
and but i was never that skilled because
i never and i always i was regretting
never going to basketball camp i had so
many friends who went to basketball camp
and they had the fundamentals got better
with that left hand
at the end of the day it's a [ __ ]
tall man sport and we're not tall so
like there were a couple guys there a
few guys there that could literally dunk
back as being one of them right the
other guy who were friend who you were
friends with he could dunk and like
you're like playing
i use an actor oh steven no not steven
uh a tall guy uh he he was on a bunch of
tv shows too he was like one of the
working oh josh josh yeah right and
these guys could dunk and we were like
at the end of the day it's like playing
volleyball with a guy that's six seven
like you're gonna
know there's no you gotta shop there's a
lot of sports where hyde is definitely
an advantage and basketball inarguably
is one which is pretty much why i was
like
playing with our buddy michael trotter
shorter than me he's like five nine five
ten maybe he's an
extreme outlaw extremely good athlete
but also like he went to tons of
basketball camps right so he he had he
had great handles like he could really
dribble the ball and i just never could
do it's really sad too because i mean i
literally basketball is my favorite
sport i played it every single day
growing up yeah i played so much
basketball well into my mid to late 20s
that it really makes no sense that i was
not ever very good i'll tell you if i
recall correctly the real reason we
stopped because i think you were 10 you
i think you came back and then i did
there there were a couple of fights that
almost broke out yeah or like literally
holding guys out there yeah and we were
like what are we doing
even if somebody early or we were in our
mid-20s i was like i don't want to get
into fist fights anymore like that's
gone but guys took it very seriously and
then they just kind of felt it was funny
to see like the guys that would roll
through too because it was kind of they
were like actors and manager like
managers i remember aaron paul rolled
through at one point this was like long
before breaking bad this is we're
talking 2002 2003. i remember aaron paul
rolling through i remember jared
paladecki is that how you pronounce his
name the guy from
oh yeah supernatural that's right he's
tall super tall super tall and very and
he's also a very good this is the kind
of [ __ ] good basketball player tall
handsome and i was like i don't need
this in my life
making you feel thinking you feel bad
about yourself yeah making you feel
small and ugly small
and talented and not athletic right and
then they want to pick a fight with me
and i got to run out of there because
they'll kick my [ __ ] ass i lose in
every way no no no no no you were you
were pretty scrappy no no
yeah you're pretty scrappy when it came
to fighting but you remember remember i
put my money on you in that fight yeah i
mean too all day
yeah yeah definitely we did a whole
episode about that yeah
do you remember do you remember the
baldwin brothers showing up yes daniel
yeah
not stephen not alec uh daniel and billy
billy billy's great okay yeah billy's
nice and billy who i did a pilot with
back in 2003 called edny yeah um so i
kind of knew billy
which one which one is the one in um uh
usual suspects
that's steve stephen i sat next to
stephen baldwin on a southwest airlines
flight to las vegas
i got a middle seat and i was jammed
between like stephen baldwin and his
like parole officer or somewhere he's
like
like sober coach or something oh you're
right you guys were all in coach
we well that's southwest so i think it's
all i don't think there is a first class
in the southwest
i'm not going to waste the money i'm
just flying to las vegas of course what
are we talking about here this is
recently this is like five years ago
you want to take a private jet to vegas
just to go listen i think i think i
think that's what the fans expect you
know i think they think that that's the
lifestyle yeah they watch an episode
like this and they're like these guys
got private jets he's good this is this
is a private gym yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's right no no no no no
we don't i was
i was i didn't get the best seat i even
get the best baldwin
[Applause]
charlie did you ever play basketball the
way you the way you uh stuffed those
kids certainly seemed to imply that you
did sure yeah i mean in my neighborhood
you played every sport right you just i
was right with my buddies and we played
plenty of basketball but i was never any
good at it terrible at it i would say
that charlie
is definitely the most athletic out of
the three of us which i think people
i don't know if the people find that
hard to believe but they're like
like when people play certain sports
with you they are surprised by how good
you are at them like you're a natural
you can swing something i like to fly i
feel as though it flusters people which
i enjoy yeah you know or they're like
why can't i drive a golf ball for this
guy absolutely i'm like oh yeah that is
true golf and baseball for sure
uh you've got an advantage so we've been
on ice
on an ice on the show right and and i
had to i had to like go out there and
learn how to skate and like it i looked
terrible and like i'm trying to and then
we would just [ __ ] around and charlie
could it just picked it right back i was
just i was in the sports i played a
shitload of sports just like we could we
could
suck we could beat him at ping pong
though you guys could be all day yeah
you could i'm terrible at a at a racket
really
you should have been singing hand-eye
coordination yeah but the angles don't
make and
i also want to like hit something as
hard as i can and have it go as far as i
can and right but you want to bash i'm
going to bash it but i i remember
watching the boggs episode which we'll
talk about at some point but we're
obviously on a on a field there and i
you know you don't usually see yourself
on camera throwing something you just
think oh you can i can i can throw a
ball right from from the mound to the
plate and i remember watching it on
camera and being like is that the way i
throw and you guys being like yes i'm
like oh that is so unathletic and but
then when you took a cut like you swung
the ball i remember i mean being like
this doesn't even make any sense he's
supposed to be hammered and why would
charlie kelly know how to hit that well
it looked like a like a like a true
baseball player's swing yeah well he
played yeah well of course baseball
probably played little league or
whatever where are you were you throwing
with your dominant hand or was that a
camera angle thing where we're like rob
you're gonna have to throw this one with
your right hand because we're
no i was throwing with my dominant hand
we we should go back we'll talk about
that a little bit ambidextrous though
i throw with my left
you've made great strides in golf i will
say when we first started playing i was
like well you know it won't be his thing
and you've gotten quite good yeah
you've gotten quite good glenn we will
eagerly await you uh you know
i'll get your presents i'll get there
i'll get there come join us you know
took me second to to come around on dogs
and uh you know now i'll come around on
golf eventually all right well i'm sure
we're thrilling the audience here should
we talk about something more salacious
sure
sure let's uh well you probably could
not make this episode in this day and
age
we could probably not make the cho the
joke where you're only picking the black
kids oh yeah for your basketball i don't
know i think i get away with that i
think so yeah yeah because it's the
characters stereotyping look i agree yes
but i do feel as though right now we're
living in a place where like well this
is just highly inappropriate and and i
think we would just take a look at it
and say well what's the best way to make
clear that this is this terrible the
terrible characters making this choice
and not the show itself like the casual
like that's where we're getting i think
some issues with previous episodes where
it's we're doing it what's seemingly
casual like as a show right where it was
like when we're just using slurs or
whatever not calling them out yeah and i
think i think this episode's okay in
that i think
i mean i think so too some of the asian
stuff is dicey no yeah but it's not that
he just said that he was in vietnam and
that he was again he has a gambling
addiction so yeah and these are his
gambling he's not saying everyone from
vietnam is that way we're just saying
that his buddies are that way yeah yeah
but i know what you mean yeah you could
you you could be a little it could be a
little dicey here and there um we
established in this episode that uh
that mary that the waitress is an
alcoholic yeah um which is another thing
that we had established in this episode
oh by the way i got to do a shout out
for my buddy uh patrick callahan who
plays the uh aaa what do you call the
person who leads the meeting the meeting
leader i don't even know sure i don't
know because i'm not enough well oh yeah
so what do you guys think are you
alcoholics yes
i think
i've taken a really good long look at it
and you know as we all know i'm not
currently not drinking but
well that's supposed to be anonymous
i think i have tendencies but i actually
don't think i i am an alcoholic i think
an actual alcoholic
literally has no control
over it like cannot stop and i i don't
know and that's how aaa defines when i
want to stop i can just stop you can
just stop and i think that's a like
i don't fixate on it it's a common theme
among alcoholics i can stop whenever i
want
yeah
but only only they can't yeah the
department i think they can't dependency
is the is the key but i think
like aa specifically or even just it's
also an obsession with it right like so
if you're if every night you're like
okay i'm not gonna have a drink tonight
and you actually don't yeah just the
better you're thinking about the fact
that you're thinking about it yes and
that you're having to make that very
very conscious you know decision to not
have a dream i do a lot of
rationalization around it so it's like
yeah like it's a it's something i think
about right so like i have
family members who drank themselves to
death i mean literally to death yeah
like sclerosis right but then you'd find
out like oh he would wake up every day
and he would start his day in the
morning
with a drink right and not stop until he
went to sleep right so i would see that
and then and then i go oh well i'm not
that i have one manhattan every night
yeah but if i don't
i'm like
i kind of have that manhattan okay yeah
but one the fact that you can have one
that's like i don't know that that's
sure that's uh
that's a habit not an addiction i think
you know some light alcoholism like yeah
i think if that's a term i'm sure that
isn't
if you're spending your entire day
thinking about that manhattan then i
don't yeah that's a different yeah
because you know you're going to have it
yes you know if but sometimes okay this
is a this is a bad sign sometimes i'll
say to myself well you know let's just
not have one tonight
and then when i get to that point i'm
like well i'll just have one
just one yeah yeah yeah yeah sure it's
just one
well you're you're addicted to one
manhattan i don't think that's so bad no
it's not yeah
that's that's okay so good yeah but if
you said you want to have in manhattan
right now i have no no no interest well
that's that that's that's good that
means that i i'd say whereas with
smoking i know some people that can just
have a couple of cigarettes i was always
that way yeah you were always good i
never no but like when you were smoking
i was smoking and we were like you know
what let's do the podcast but let's just
can we make this a smoky move yeah we
would just be hacking butts in here yeah
i i wouldn't i mean i haven't had a
cigarette in a long time almost 20 years
but like wow i have
yeah yeah but i can i can just have one
on the rare occasion i just have like
one
and it's great yeah glorious i wish i
could do that i thought i could but you
probably at this point like why bother
yeah yeah yeah no i think
i i think the pandemic has probably not
done a lot of us too many favors with
regard to um
alcohol drinking yeah alcohol abuse uh
epidemic it's just a total scam by the
alcohol companies trying to drink more
man it worked it worked
it sure did boy sure did it was funny
because there was a time where because i
never used to drink at home really uh
which may be a surprise to people they
probably assume that i drink all the
time but i don't um
i used to almost never almost never
drink at home it made no sense to me i
made no sense to me ever i was one of
those people like wouldn't drink all
week and then i'd go out on friday night
me too and get absolutely me too that's
what i would do too yeah i never but
monday through friday monday through
thursday or sunday through thursday you
and i lived together yeah we would never
drink during the week never at all i
don't even know that we even kept beer
in the fridge maybe i know and then but
then friday night we'd just go get
blackout drunk yeah exactly exactly so
i'd make up for it over the weekend you
know by getting absolutely hammered but
uh but yeah it wasn't wasn't like a and
then
you know and and drinking was always
like it was like a special social yeah
it was a social thing but that's when it
gets that's when it got weird for me it
was like over the pandemic i started
like let me just have a glass of whiskey
or whatever you know what i mean yeah
and it was nice we got loose you know
put the kids to bed you're kind of loose
a little more giggly than usual just
whatever
and then i i remember there being like
almost a switch where i was like
i would have a drink and just and i'd be
like i'd be like just it just made me
tired
and i'm like why isn't this fun anymore
and it was somebody's i gotta have two
that had to make it fun yeah because
well by the way that is what would
happen i would have this i'd be like
well the second one that'll get me going
and then i know that would be more tired
and irritated yeah yeah you're not able
to get that dopamine rush because you're
doing it all the time well and also but
i think it also isn't somebody had to
point this out i was like i don't know
why it just it doesn't feel the same and
they were like yeah because you used to
drink socially now you're just drinking
yeah not socially you're just you're
just it's just your kids are screaming
and you're drinking yeah and it's now
it's making you irritated i'm like oh
yeah that's that is what's happening i
just got to the point where i'm like my
my body in my life was like that's what
i can't like
have a couple beers every night for the
rest of my life what am i doing
it's nice because you're serving you
love beer i love beer that's your thing
so you would drink beer so yeah it's a
high calorie alcohol
it's a high sure i don't really care
about that that's a lot but it's a lot
of liquid
yeah sure i'm not i'm not suggesting but
it's like it's more of a commitment
like i can drink in manhattan in like i
think like 10 minutes
see but then that would i would be like
well i need something to be sipping on
now yeah just for the habit that's the
good thing about a beer is it lasts
longer because you drink fast you know
that's true yeah
yeah i love alcohol i mean i just do
yeah something man maybe you are an
alcoholic yeah no i said i said yes he
had said it right off the bat he said
that he was well yeah i said yes you
know it hasn't ruined my life
all signs are pointing towards things
continuing yeah yeah it takes one
one decision to get behind that wheel
100
that i'm very careful about that oh yeah
no that's that's that's been what that's
the best thing about uber that is like a
saving lives left and right yeah guys
this episode brought to you by
honda
[Music]
have you guys ever done community
service yeah yeah me too yeah oh boy
really yeah okay sure interesting yeah
where did you have to do a community
service for charlie what did you do
busted
drinking
oh yeah yeah i definitely have been
an alcoholic in periods of my life for
sure um but i was 20
20. i was 20 years old and i was with a
pack of other 20 year olds and cops
busted in this party and they're like
all right someone just you know snitch
who bought the beer and we'll let you go
and we're not a bunch of [ __ ]
snitches so nobody said [ __ ] and they
arrested us all
and uh you know you know we gotta like
slap on the wrist how to do communities
how many hours do you remember
i don't recall i don't even really
recall what i did for the community
service you don't remember what you did
no must have not meant that much to you
sure to do something for the community
did it uh rob what did you what what a
couple of times but it was all similar
things you know like stupid you know
disturbing the peace yeah you know like
drunkenness and yeah yeah again or like
battery in height right great no
peaceful city of philadelphia and you're
disturbing it you've been disturbed
uh would you miss that man what did you
have to do for community service like
pick up trash on the side of the road oh
did they give you a choice did or did
they assign you something
i don't remember i think maybe yeah was
it maybe they were like well you can
either do this or either do that or
something i remember at one point they
in in new jersey they gave you you could
either pay a fine or do the service
and then there was a class action
lawsuit against uh
new jersey and that like that got
eradicated yeah because people could
just people who with money could just be
like all right [ __ ] it i'll just pay
yeah right i mean that's not fair you're
not doing a service to the community
that way
let's get this guy who's disturbing the
peace
to do a service for the community maybe
yes you um i uh made an extremely bad uh
uh error in judgment uh when i was going
to college down in miami florida oh yeah
yeah sure arguably you know the three of
us
what you do what you did could have got
you into more trouble then oh
even though we have all oh god you tell
the truth well i mean so yeah i tried to
get a fake driver's license from the dmv
down in miami um and they took that very
very seriously and i was actually
charged with this is crazy to think
about i was charged with four felonies
yeah so technically i have four felonies
on my record um now he got expunged
because i was a first time offender so
um
you know the they they were they were
lenient but i don't think i could join
the fbi you know what i mean like that
so on a regular background check it
wouldn't come up um
[Music]
at this point we all had everybody's got
a fake id or at least we all had [ __ ]
ids at one point but they were actually
fake yes or you'd get somebody else's
documentation but when you go in and try
to pretend to be somebody else to get
actual government issued
like legal documents yeah that that is
well it's a felony it was a serious
serious offense every time i signed my
name they had me sign my name three four
times and for every signature was a
felony
they they they threw the they they threw
the book at me they threw that florida
does not [ __ ] around yeah that's
not really known for crime in florida
not really no no there's a pretty uh
pretty peaceful um yeah well-adjusted
people that live in living in florida
wait wait wait wait wait wait charlie
stay so much my community service no my
community service so i remember them
giving me a giant list of uh choices and
for some reason i don't know why i chose
this i just thought it would be
interesting i'm like well if i'm going
to do it i want it to be something
interesting not something mindless
so i was actually an assistant
english teacher i would drive to this
high school which at night became a
night school
and there were um a bunch of uh haitian
immigrants that were there uh trying to
learn english and i was teaching them
how to speak english
they're like give them give them the
felon what i mean
florida is the best crazy
is the craziest place ever yeah this
guy's is people's identities potentially
let's introduce him to a room full of
new immigrants that's [ __ ] nuts yeah
and i don't speak it's not like i speak
french so i couldn't you know but most
of them spoke well enough to where um i
could communicate
yeah but there was i wasn't the teacher
i was like the teacher's assistant so i
was there assisting but it was a lot i
did like 80 hours yeah you were a felon
it was yeah
well there's three striking examples of
white privilege 100 that's literally
what i was thinking about as we were
talking about
how fun it is to get arrested yeah it's
so fun
beyond the wrist they give you the
community service and
my experience was not fun guys well
there's much more to my story there's
much more to my story where i was i mean
i was in jail i was in [ __ ] prison it
was it was horrible yeah it was horrible
okay i did not feel privileged um at
that particular moment in my life
um but uh but yeah considering the the
final result yeah there's some there's
probably some privilege there
yeah for sure well
see ya
yeah yeah i mean that's another good one
that's a good one you know or is it or a
bad one i don't know and i guess this is
the creative process you know we just
try these podcasts and sometimes they
work sometimes they don't yeah yeah i
guess let's go get a drink yeah yeah
let's do it
you